bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actus sur tv
fils le journal de la rédaction 26
minutes pour traiter l'essentiel de
l'information locale voici les titres
les rythmes scolaires à la verrière ça
avance la ville des volets son
organisation pour septembre prochain à
guyancourt vient de se tenir un forum
emploi handicap les candidats pouvaient
présenter leur cv et passer des
entretiens avec les entreprises et les
collectivités publiques présenté puis de
gens de jemmapes fondateur de la
compagnie le black blanc beur fête les
30 ans de hip hop 30 ans de sa troupe
surtout avec en guise d'apéritif deux de
ses créations historiques à redécouvrir
à la merise ce week end à trappes
l'image du jour ce sont ces immeubles à
trappes qui suscite l intérêt du député
et ancien ministre ump benoist apparu il
sera ce lundi soir à la maison des
associations pour rencontrer les
locataires des squares léo lagrange
jules verne jules védrines ou encore
maurice thorez et il répond à
l'invitation du collectif trappe
citoyens du candidat divers droite aux
municipales othman menaceront le jeune
candidat qui défie donc le maire sortant
sur l'un des dossiers phares de son
mandat le logement ottomane nasri qui
reproche à l'équipe actuelle de ne pas
défendre assez les habitants face à des
bailleurs sociaux jeux sites peu
scrupuleux
toujours à trappes on notera également
qu'aujourd'hui ont été relaxés à deux
frères accusés d'avoir insulté une jeune
fille voilée en juillet dernier une
peine de six mois ferme avaient été
requises par le procureur à versailles
c'est le manque de preuves qui a
justifié cette décision
la fronde gagne de plus en plus d'élus
en matière de rythmes scolaires on pense
notamment au long cours ou le maire jean
michel fourgous appelle même à ne pas
appliquer la réforme c'est un débat qui
va également sans doute animé le congrès
des maires de france et qui se tient
depuis ce mardi à paris dans d'autres
villes pourtant le processus de
concertation avance c'est le cas à la
verrière la commune a présenté ce samedi
son planning pour 2014 4 nuls à taux et
jonathan vilma
les rythmes scolaires font râler dans
certaines villes d'autres par contre
s'organise semble-t-il plus
tranquillement à la verrière voici à
quoi ressemblera la vie scolaire des
enfants à la rentrée 2014 ils
travailleront le mercredi matin
concernant le planning et plutôt rassuré
cache pas qu on était super inquiète on
fait partie des enseignants ont fait la
grève on a fermé notre école jeudi
dernier
sans connaître en fait tous les détails
concernant l'élémentaire on est plutôt
rassuré une réunion de présentation
s'est tenue ce samedi l'aboutissement
d'une vingtaine de réunions de
concertation avec les parents et les
enseignants où finalement tout le monde
a fait un pas vers l'autre nous avions
préconisé préconisé nous en tant que
parents d'élèves des activités plus tôt
en début d'après midi
maintenant
on comprend aussi que si on veut des
activités de qualité
1h30 c'était c'est mieux pour avoir ses
activités et donc donc une réunion en
début d'après midi ça devenait un petit
peu compliqué donc effectivement le
basculement deuxième partie d'après-midi
nous on a fait deux choix forts premier
choix de travailler sur la pause
méridienne en l'élargissant un peu et en
lui donnant un peu plus de contenu pour
faciliter le travail des enseignants
deuxièmement un choix de faire d'étape
des temps d'activités périscolaires pour
les enfants d'âge élémentaires d'une
heure trente pour avoir la qualité au
rendez vous cette qualité a un prix il
va falloir recruter des animateurs
adapter les locaux scolaires la ville de
la verrière a estimé le coût de la
réforme à 150000 euros dont la moitié
soutenu par l'état et la caisse
d'allocations familiales dans son
travail la commune compte s'appuyer sur
les associations locales la ligue de
l'enseignement a joué le rôle
d'accompagnateur
on va accompagner la commune sur la une
réflexion de fond
et de la formation aussi du personnel
sur la pause méridienne parce que c'est
un enjeu très important dans les
yvelines parmi les 262 communes du
département 8 ont fait le choix de
changer de rythme scolaire à la rentrée
de septembre 2013 les autres communes
ont jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre
pour présenter leur premier projet
le marché de l'emploi toujours tendu et
la situation est encore plus compliqué
lorsqu'on présente un handicap un forum
de recrutement spécialisés se tenait
aujourd'hui à saint quentin en yvelines
clair qu'en billets pour les précisions
à guyancourt des centaines de personnes
se pressaient ce mardi à ce forum de
l'emploi un forum ouvert exclusivement
aux travailleurs handicapés en 2012 on
en comptabilisait 6400 dans le
département handicapé physique en
fauteuil sourds-muets malvoyants ou
déficients mentaux ici pour une fois on
oublie leur handicap pour s'intéresser à
leurs compétences on sent que les gens
sont réceptifs je pense qu'ils sont
formés par rapport au handicap aussi
vous dans leur propre entreprise dont
qu'ils ont pas le même regard des
structures de travail spécialisés
existent mais la majorité d'entre eux 85
% peuvent travailler dans le circuit
classique et pourtant les recruteurs
restent frileux leur taux de chômage est
deux fois supérieur la moyenne nationale
un petit peu nous lisons des coop on est
un petit peu isolé il faut dire ce qui
est on est isolé partout ici abdelkader
peut aller à la rencontre des 45
exposants et tenter sa chance son face à
face auprès de recruteurs pour faciliter
leur venue un véhicule spécialisé fait
la navette gratuitement vers la gare et
deux interprètes sont présentes pour les
sourds et muets à ce stand on s'occupe
également de les conseiller en image
alors là vous êtes à l'atelier
colorimétrie donc la colorimétrie c'est
encore une fois donc c'est la découverte
des couleurs qui vont vous mettre en
valeur se mettre en valeur et se sentir
en confiance mais ce genre d'événement
ne réglera pas tout on se rend compte
que globalement le public des personnes
en situation de handicap en recherche
d'emploi sont des personnes qui n'ont
pas encore un niveau de qualification
forcément totalement en adéquation avec
les parce qu'on peut proposer pour les
cdi en tout cas c'est beaucoup des
postes
génial bac + 5 plutôt technique et donc
du coup ces cinq sa lunette un petit peu
si les mentalités changent petit à petit
et que l'on retrouve aujourd'hui des
personnes handicapées à la place des
recruteurs il reste encore du chemin
pour atteindre l'équité
sport non pas pour parler de football
mais plutôt de gymnastique plus de 500
gymnastes étaient réunis tout au long du
week end à elle en cours pour une
compétition régionale première étape
vers les championnats de france ce qui
constitue parfois le rêve de certaines
compétitrices qu'a rencontrées pour nous
anthony rech
l'uni d'objets imposé comme le ruban ou
le ballon chaque gymnaste ne disposait
que de quelques minutes pour convaincre
le jury par sa précision et sa grâce est
arrivé à ne faire qu'un avec son
accessoire le plus difficile dirait le
rubin est ce que ça s'en mêle et c'est
un engin très difficile à manipuler moi
c'est le cerceau fort parce que ton qui
fait des lancers
c'est un peu plus facile et puis c'est
joli à regarder aussi cette compétition
régionale individuelle était
qualificative pour les étapes zonal au
mois de décembre première marche vers
les championnats de france parfois le
rêve ultime des gymnastes présentes
elles encourent ce week-end c'est déjà
une grande compétition il ya beaucoup de
personnes pour moi ça représente
un peu près que son ami pierre s bat
j'aimerais bien être prend le même et on
contiennent rien jusqu'au bout dans ma
catégorie en individuel et en a pas mais
en équipe
il y en a et j'espère pouvoir monter sur
le podium ici sur les deux jours de
compétition plus de 500 gymnastes se
sont succédé sur le praticable
chez les juniors marion termine sixième
de son côté la jeune anaïs etienne
finira au pied du podium mais avec le
sourire
il avait débuté en mars 2012 l'un des
plus grands chantiers en ile de france
concernant le patrimoine selon la
municipalité de plaisir est bel et bien
terminé la rénovation de l'église saint
pierre a même donné lieu à une cérémonie
d'inauguration au cours du week-end
il aura fallu un an et demi pour que
l'église saint-pierre de plaisir
retrouvé de sa superbe
un an et quelques millions d'euros +27
dont trois consacrés à la place située
devant l'édifice réflexion et étanchéité
des sols la restauration des vitraux de
l'orgue des menuiseries ou encore
réfection des façades et changement du
chauffage partie qu'on a pris au départ
c'est justement de renforcer d'abord de
conserver tout ce qui restait de cette
petite église rurale ces éléments de
décor ces éléments de mobilier etc son
architecture bien sûr mais aussi de
renforcer ses 7,7 identité en restaurant
très très scrupuleusement tous et tous
ces vestiges anciens et puis dans les
équipements dans les compléments qui
était nécessaire de rester dans la menée
dans le même esprit et dans le temps la
même identité les plaisirs roy qui avait
été appelé à soutenir financièrement le
projet via une souscription populaire
redécouvre l'édifice érigé au xiiie
siècle quant à l'évêque de versailles il
parle de soulagement pour les
paroissiens ça fait 18 mois que ne
pouvaient plus entrer dans l'église je
pouvais plus prier dans l'église et
retrouver leur église cette maman
formidable alors c'est vrai que pendant
18 mois on a été dans les paroisses
voisines qu'elles nous ont très bien
accueillis mais là c'est retrouver
l'église et non seulement leur trouver
mais la retrouver le belle que jamais
pour marquer l'événement la façade de
l'église saint-pierre sera illuminé
jusqu'au 15 juin
est l'invité de cette édition du 7 8
cela que tu sais j'en jemal bonsoir
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau
fondateur de black blanc beur compagnie
de danse qui dans quelques mois fêtera
ses 30 ans 30 ans de danse avec
plusieurs événements prévus on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir dans quelques
instants mais déjà l'apéritif qui sera
servi ce sera à la mairie de la trappe
avec une représentation le 23 novembre à
partir de 20h30 de deux spectacles l'un
qui marque
spectacle historique de la compagnie on
va en parler c'est si je t'aime mais une
autre c'est à est une création ça
s'appelle paradoxe c'est un projet de
formation peu particulier puisque c'est
de la formation d'insertion
professionnelle de jeunes danseurs se
sont eux qui vont se produire sur la
scène de la merise dans quelques jours
absolument j'en ai justement insertion
ou parce que nous on dit plutôt
formation voilà voilà des gens qui sont
venus non seulement de leur plein gré
mais pas par désir par goût pour
pratiquer la danse qui ont tous un
emploi et qui sont donc que des jeunes
gens et des jeunes filles originaire de
trappes et de saint quentin en yvelines
qui travaillent avec nous depuis
maintenant près de trois ans sur ce
processus de création ces clips pas du
jour au lendemain qu'elle se sont
retrouvés sur la scène non seulement il
sort tout au long de ces différents
seulement non seulement ils sont peu
retrouvé du jour au lendemain sur la
scène mais il avait envie de faire un
vrai spectacle de qualité donc on s'est
pris le temps de le faire et surtout
l'idée c'était que il ont apprécié que
nous ne souhaitions pas leur imposer une
thématique ou une démarche et il faut
prendre le temps quand on travaille
ensemble parce que on parle de co
élaboration de co création mais pour
cela il faut évidemment que nos
partenaires ces jeunes gens et ces
jeunes filles aient le temps de
construire une réflexion de l'alimenter
et voilà donc nous sommes partis de leur
envie de faire spectacle
une idée au départ qui était un peu la
vengeance des pauvres contre les riches
et s'était spontanément ce qu'ils
voulaient mettre en forme donner à voir
et nous sommes parvenus
christine notamment qui les a
accompagnés avec mathieu ragots elle
tout au long de ce parcours son appel un
chorégraphe qui a fondé avec vos
l'accompagnent absolument et qui est
surtout la personne référente de ce
projet c'est celui que les danseurs et
danseuses en question voir régulièrement
nous sommes parvenus à un spectacle dont
le titre et paradoxes mais qu'il a
traité du paradoxe de la richesse ce qui
est quand même une sorte de mise à
distance ou disons la vengeance la
colère le sentiment un peu spontané ans
a été remis de côté pour évoquer
peut-être plus largement la question de
qu'est ce qu'être riche ce sera à
découvrir un samedi à partir de 20h30 à
la merise il reste encore des places si
vous souhaitez y assister il ya aussi
deux représentations pour les scolaires
21 22 novembre peut-être faites-vous
partie des parents dont les enfants vous
revenir le soir vous parler d'un
spectacle ce sera celui ci paradoxe il
faudra ensuite aller le voir le samedi
voici un petit extrait un petit teaser
paradoxe à la mairie c'est l'un des
spectacles de black blanc beur à
découvrir au cours du week-end l'un des
spectacles parce qu'il y en aura deux
mais juste pour conclure sur paradoxe
est une version courte c'est une façon
30 minutes il a trente premières minutes
de ce travail très élaborés et très
exigeant nous sommes en route ils ont
davantage que 30 minutes à l'heure
actuelle mais nous sommes en train de
terminer l'équipe qu'ils encadrent est
en train de terminer un format à une
heure qui sera présentée elle en 2014
dans le cadre alors là de nos 30 ans à
proprement parler conscient que les
trente ans c'est en 2014 31 officiel
autre spectacle à re découvrir celui ci
met au jour dans le cadre de cette
programmation à la mairie ce sera au
cours de la même soirée c'est si je
t'aime catastrophe m c'est une des
pièces clefs un petit peu la compagnie
raisons disons que sur une trentaine de
création il ya 14 15 pièces qui sont
considérés aujourd'hui comme des des
moments vraiment originaux majeurs qui
ont marqué à la fois l'histoire de la
compagnie mais aussi l'histoire de ceux
de cette danse de cette manière de faire
la danse hip hop si je t'aime et
emblématique pour plusieurs raisons mais
au moins une s'éteint c'est sur le thème
du couple et c'est un thème récurrent
dans le travail de christine coudun la
chorégraphe de la compagnie et le hip
hop justement côté femmes cette fois ci
alors nous parle du couple on y parle
des femmes a annoncé le couple donc
c'est les hommes les femmes et puis tout
ce qui le couple les relations g c'est
quelque chose qui est pas forcément
souvent traités dans le nord du mont et
hip hop global on parle de la culture
hip hop puis pas toujours de manière
très adroite aussi là ça se traduit
comment sur scène cette création d'abord
la particularité c'est que c'est la
musique n'est pas de la musique hip hop
ou alors vraiment très accidentellement
un moment donné on y campe il ya de la
musique classique il ya de la musique de
jazz bref c'est comment dirais-je
ça parle du couple dans le milieu qui
est le nôtre dans le milieu de danses
dans le milieu de ses danseurs qui au
moment de la création avait entre 20 et
25 ans et ça disons pause l'ensemble des
questions des problématiques qui peuvent
être posées aux couples dans ces âges là
donc aussi tout un côté sur sur le rêve
sur le rêve des tropiques 20 voilà black
blanc beur lorsqu'on évoque la compagnie
on pense au hip hop vous êtes à la fois
dans le hip hop mais aussi en dehors
vous me disiez avec cette création la
vous voulez aussi toucher d'autres
styles culturel on va parler des 30 ans
de black blanc beur qui se profile vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi cette
volonté d'être à la croisée de de tous
les genres ce sera juste après ce micro
trottoir nous vous avons posé cette
question aujourd'hui quelle image
avez-vous du hip hop à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui une très bonne image on
voit qu'aujourd'hui le hip hop c'est une
musique qui n'est qu' aux harkis qui
n'est pas réservé qu'aux jeunes pas ce
qu'est un message de la morale et à une
histoire aussi c'est une musique qui de
plusieurs horizons écouter de partout et
qui est qui se veut festive donc se
sont tous c'est pour ça qu'elles
touchent beaucoup plus les jeunes
semblent assez à une façon de s'exprimer
différemment ça permet
de laisser sa créativité ça permet
vraiment exprimé avec son corps et de
faire passer un message qui est
différent comme comme le rap finalement
ça permet de faire défiler une
information différemment que que ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'entendre nos
devoirs pour moi actuellement le hip hop
perd sa place
comparé au temps d'avant c'est à dire on
écoute de moins en moins le hip hop elle
est remplacée par le 2 3 type de musique
tels que la technique une tectonique ou
autre au style plus dans les bouts des
jeunes aujourd'hui tout simplement
magret qu'à l'époque ça passer certains
messages passés par cette musique là est
donc aujourd'hui on perd cette notion là
tout simplement par rapport aux jeunes
ça les incite parfois la violence
mais
on peut aussi comprendre leur souffrance
souvent ils viennent des cités de
banlieue et on peut comprendre la
souffrance
qu'ils vivent au quotidien
hip hop violence hip hop style oui je
suis pareil forcément
je n'espère pas mais j'ai un commentaire
à faire à l'endroit des personnes que
vous avez interviewé d'abord la première
personne considère lui pape à travers ce
qu'elle en connaît c'est à dire la
musique c'est le moment de rappeler que
le hip hop est un grand mouvement
culturel pour pas dire politique qui
nous est arrivé des etats-unis mais qui
était déjà la transformation finalement
des différentes postures con con vu les
noirs les africains pendant plusieurs
siècles pour pouvoir développer leur
culture et les formes au rituel de devis
qui sont entre eux donc ça n'est pas que
de la musique mais ce qu'il dit est fort
juste pour réagir sur la seconde
personne elle considérait plutôt la
danse parce qu'elle parlait de corps ces
moments de dire que c'est aussi du
deejaying des gens qui font du dj que
c'est aussi des graffeurs des gens qui
font des grades d'ailleurs je vois que
le graff de tv fils pas que tu habites
les filles s'est inspiré c'est quelque
chose qui est rentré j'allais dire dans
l'esthétique du helmand dans paraît
absolument après avec plus ou moins de
bonheur et quand le dernier
interlocuteur parle de violence il est
certain qu'un certain nombre de musiques
de hip hop ou du rap sont parfois le
reflet effectivement des violences ce
subit souvent
peut-être en générer je crois pas qu'on
puisse généraliser à l'ensemble de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler disons la culture
hip hop black blanc beur et mais il y à
bientôt 30 ans 1984 septembre on va
refaire un peu l'historique on en a déjà
parlé forcément sur cette antenne mais
c'est toujours intéressant de voir un
petit peu comment est née cette
compagnie c'était un spectacle presque
anodin 40 danseurs s'étaient attention
un parking à saint quentin en yvelines
on était loin d'imaginer que la
compagnie puisse ensuite se produire à
l'international parce que c'est
complètement complètement enfin en tout
cas
nous avons l'ambition de faire un
travail d'excellence enfin de la
meilleure qualité possible nous avions
l'ambition d'avoir dix ont une réussite
régionale puisque c'était quand même la
mission de là parce qu'à l'époque que
pour les pour laquelle l'association
socioculturelle du départ de la ville
nouvelle quand c'était encore une vie
nouvelle saint quentin en yvelines qui
avait mission de développer les formes
émergentes de la 2e artistique de la
jeunesse donc oui nous souhaitions bien
sûr que ça marche le plus possible et
c'est vrai que nous avons été
extrêmement surpris par le résultat et
le fait qu'on se retrouve quasiment
trois mois après à l'international vous
êtes retrouvés dans cette aventure
médecin à l'origine
aux karatékas c'est déjà beaucoup plus
proche non c'est surtout lié à la
mission que j'avais accepté de mener
pour la passe qui était au départ une
mission d'étude que j'avais souhaité
mettre en oeuvre comme une étude actions
et l'action s'était justement
d'expérimenter un certain nombre de
processus ce qui est important à
l'époque c'est que la passe qui était un
véritable lieu socioculturel où il n'y
avait pas de distinction entre
l'émancipation et la sachant que
aujourd'hui dans une compagnie comme la
nôtre on retrouve ce paradoxe là encore
de gérer l'art pour l'art et l'art utile
je reprends cette expression qui vient
de jacqueline chine qui est notre grand
maître du théâtre de l'unité qui nous
avait justement donné le goût de tenter
les choses et de ne pas se sentir
forcément perdant d'avancé maintenant ce
qui peut être important à signaler à
l'époque c'est que un projet comme
celui-ci qui fut de danse ou d'autre
chose avait une particularité qui à mon
avis faut continuer à défendre
aujourd'hui c'est l'idée que la
confrontation à un art ou disons à la
science bref des des contenus qui
permettent d'apprendre à réfléchir
qui permettent de mieux se connaître soi
même de trouver la meilleure distance de
soi aux autres d'être plus juste et donc
de produire autour de soi de belle
transformation a été la philosophie
pendant 30 ans absolument d'ailleurs le
slogan début j'avais dit aux danseurs ce
sera ni misérable ni exotiques voilà et
nous ne sommes pas plus qu'aujourd'hui
misérable ni exotiques et une remarque
part parce qu'on vous disiez tout à
l'heure ville fritz et que en effet
cette nous n'avons jamais été
complètement dans le hip hop tel qu'il a
pu se définir à partir de la rue et nous
avons été clairs sur le fait que c'est
un travail qu'on faisait de la rue à la
scène mais nous n'avons jamais été non
plus
dehors
quinze ans avant la plupart des grandes
compagnies nous avions déjà un processus
extrêmement clair et aujourd'hui nous
sommes encore sur ce territoire car
c'était à nos engagements nous n'avons
choisi de ne pas intégrer une
institution publique un centre
chorégraphique
parce que pour nous l'important c'était
sans doute d'aller dans les lieux les
plus prestigieux du monde mais aussi de
revenir à trappes de revenir à saint
quentin et de pouvoir procéder à un
échange de bon aloi 2014 la compagnie à
30 ans il y aura forcément des
spectacles y aura des expositions des
documentaires on aura l'occasion d'en
parler tout au long du début de l'année
prochaine chez l'humain on vous tiendra
bien évidemment informé vous reviendrai
sur ce plateau avec vos danseurs avec
également les autres membres fondateurs
juste pour conclure s'il y avait non pas
un souvenir a gardé de ses 30 ans mais
un souvenir peut-être à imaginer à rêver
pour les 30 prochaines années ce serait
quoi
le que me rayer pour la campagne que
pour la compagnie et c'est marrant parce
que bon la compagnie en fin de compte
c'est le lieu d effectivement de la mise
en forme des rêves et de la mise à l'eau
jaillir en beauté de tout ce que nous
tentons de mettre au travail
en termes de réflexion et en termes des
changes avec un public donc pour black
blanc beur mais bien au delà de black
blanc beur mon souhait ça serait que
lier davantage de modernisation de
l'éducation populaire pour que de
nouveau là le sport la culture
la santé soient réunies de telle sorte à
ce que les jeunes et les moins jeunes
puissent se construire eux mêmes une
autonomie et une cape une émancipation
qui ne soit pas prescrite d'en haut par
les institutions ou par disons les les
savants et les gens dont la pensée a
cours à un moment ou un autre c'est là
mon voeu le plus cher et si vous voulez
commencé à goûter à cette philosophie si
vous ne la connaissez pas de black blanc
beur rendez-vous à la merise attrape
pour découvrir l'une des créations
emblématiques si je t'aime et puis
également une création qui commence tout
juste qui est encore en cours
d'élaboration dans une version un peu
plus longues ces paradoxes merci jean
avec les b trop juniors et les
investissements ce label parce que
effectivement ils se sont mis à une
hauteur qu'on n'attendait pas non plus
mais du coup il en est ravi merci à vous
et jean djoman merci où il fait on
termine ce journal par une information
peu plus insolite une famille de jouy en
josas l'origine d'une cabane totalement
novatrice elle est faite à partir de
carton recyclé modulable elle peut se
monte et se démonte et en quelques
minutes des co a également selon ses
propres goûts al'approche de noël l'idée
pourrait peut-être séduire parents et
enfants et yolaine 13 avec ses cinq
associés famille amie corinne était
certaine que le produit existait déjà
pourtant leur idée est totalement
novatrice ces cabanes en carton recyclé
et modulable n'existe nulle part
ailleurs pas même à l'étranger vous
pouvez vraiment créer la forme de la
cabane que vous souhaitez ces deux jeux
en un vous pouvez d'une créer la forme
de la cabane donc ça peut être une forme
octogonale ça peut être à labyrinthes ça
peut être une maison avec différentes
petites pièces où les enfants peuvent se
cacher et ensuite l'enfant peut décorer
la cabane donc vraiment le côté novateur
c'est pour la première fois construire
la cabane qu'on veut créer son univers
créé son décor créé son monde et vous
verrez que les enfants créée en fait à
chaque fois à chaque fois qu'ils
ressortent la cabane vaut créer une
forme de cabanes différentes ça sera
jamais la même l idée est lié à son
enfance son père était publicitaires et
ramener souvent les cartons qui ne
servaient plus à la maison
avec ses deux frères corinne s'en
servait alors pour créer des cabanes ces
cabanes ma baraque sont commercialisés
depuis le mois de septembre avant
corinne à tester son produit auprès des
centres de loisirs résultat un produit
solide non dangereux mais surtout très
pédagogique pour les enfants avec le
système d'encoches ils apprennent à
maîtriser leurs gestes mais pas
seulement ça va permettre également de
développer la créativité et
l'imagination enfants puisqu'il va créer
à chaque fois une cabane différentes et
également l'imagination et la créativité
puisqu'il va aller à décorer selon ses
propres envies dès l'âge de 3 ans la
cabane ne peut se monte et se démonte et
en trois quatre minutes chrono
démonstration avec deux des trois
enfants de corinne
l'idée semble faire des adeptes sur leur
première production corinne et son
équipe en ont déjà vendu la moitié tout
est stocké dans son garage donc ici nous
avons des parts commandé 400 cabane il
nous en reste plus que deux sens puisque
nous avons écoulé déjà la moitié du
stock et nous avons encore beaucoup de
voiliers tout ça ce sont des boîtes qui
sont en attente de livraison pour des
hôpitaux pour des centres de vacances ou
encore pour des écoles l'activité lui
prend beaucoup de place et de temps mais
elle reste pour le moment un plus par
rapport à son premier métier de maître
de conférences en marketing
ce qui n'empêche pas d'avoir déjà
d'autres idées de développement créé du
mobilier en carton pour meubler la
cabane ou encore créer le même produit
en version plus petite pour en faire des
maisons de poupées corinne et son équipe
n'ont pas fini d'innover l approche de
noël ma baraque risque de faire quelques
heureux ils seront d'ailleurs présents
au marché noël de jouy en josas les 13
et 14 décembre prochains
le journal revient mercredi nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité locale
excellente soirée sur notre antenne